and you know what while we're talking
about some of the stupidest things
imaginable that a human being can say
let's talk about Herschel Walker right
Herschel Walker
this week
came out
in his opposition to the inflation
reduction act and I am so sorry it's so
hard to keep a straight face and do this
sometimes
and he said that uh you know
we don't need additional spending on
environmental issues because aren't
there enough trees already
let me re let me read his exact
statement
they continue to try to fool you that
they are helping out but they're not
because a lot of money it's going to
trees don't we have enough trees around
here
climate chainsaw folks we're done pack
it up environmentalists we've had a
great run but Herschel Walker just
exposed the whole thing there's there's
already trees out there they've seen the
trees folks what are we gonna do they
know the trees exist
yeah
look
look okay
I I don't
I don't want to be just exceptionally
hard on Herschel Walker okay I know he
has had a difficult life
he has openly talked
about you know mental problems that he
has had and I do not want to pile onto
that and I do not want to you know act
like an ableist here at all
what I will say however with regard to
policy
is that this statement is unfortunately
not an aberration
these are the kinds of things that
conservatives say to get you to think
that any action to protect the
environment to make the climate not hit
that point of no return is stupid
right in their eyes we are the stupid
ones because we want to protect the
planet we're the stupid ones
because we don't want to kill 1400
people a year
in the United States alone with air
pollution we're crazy for thinking that
that my God what if we just made things
better for people that makes us the
weirdos
no
somebody who's going out there saying we
got enough trees out here what are we
doing that's the weirdo
the weirdos are the ones who bring
snowballs onto the floor of the senate
in wintertime and say well climate
change is done
we are witnessing right now in this
country today look out your dang windows
you see climate change
if you're in Texas you're seeing it
firsthand if you're in Colorado in
California you're seeing it firsthand
down here in Florida we're seeing it
firsthand New Orleans seeing it
firsthand
and countless other places all across
the country
a couple more trees here and there isn't
going to solve it and no by the way for
the record we do not have enough trees
out there either
but Herschel Walker is carrying on in
that long Republican tradition of
denying that climate change exists and
then trying to reduce it to its most
ridiculous form listen that's all the
time we have for today we got a
wonderful members only bonus show coming
up for you in just a little bit but if
you want more from me fair and cousins
you can find me youtube.com the ring of
fire I'm also at youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and I'm Twitter Instagram
and Facebook at fair and balanced thank
you so much for tuning in this is the
David packman show we'll see you next
time